this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king the paid
off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host christy wright ramsey
personality the creator of
business boutique and all things christy
wright
is uh my co-host today as we take your
calls about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five speaking of business
boutique
you were saying right before we went on
the air that popped up on your phone
there's five years ago today
that the book was uh in launch mode
you're in your first week of launch
yeah it was launch week we were in
nashville for the signing it was one of
those memories that came up on my phone
it's hard to believe five years ago the
book came out but it's
incredible too because this book
continues to sell you see this and it
continues to help people it's the plan
to help them get their business idea off
the ground and grow it so
equipping women to make money doing what
they love yeah i can't believe we've
been saying that five years it seems
like it's 20 minutes
of course of course the book launched as
a number one best seller
and it's all about equipping women to
make money doing what they love
to go with that around that same time i
guess maybe
in the f months following that we
launched business boutique
academy yeah which is all about christie
teaching
ladies how to start and how to run a
business
yeah so this is really just our coaching
model because it came out of our first
event in 2015
we had these amazing success stories but
women would come home from the event
they're fired up but then they're
thinking oh well
i ran into something i didn't know how
to deal with or i lost motivation or i
got discouraged a few months later when
i thought you know i want to
walk with them over time in their
business
i want to help them have the motivation
but also the advice and tools and steps
they need to take and so
we launched the academy back in 2016
and it has been incredible i've had
women that that joined in 2016 that have
stayed with me and
you have some that have been joining
since then but it's a six month
coaching period this is not a you know a
private facebook group where we just sit
around talk this is you actually teach
them to freaking do stuff
and they go freaking do it yeah we have
a this is serious business
it is and it's interesting too because
it doesn't matter what type of business
you're in
you're all in business i have the most
common question i i am asked dave is
but what about this type of business but
what about a salon but what about
fitness coaching but what about
multi-level marketing nonprofit
for-profit what
it does you're all in business and
that's what i specialize in i want to
teach you the
business principles that you take and
apply to your specific business to help
you win
and so uh so yeah we only open twice a
year
we're open right now we opened yesterday
we close thursday night
and what we do is we have an open
enrollment where new members can come in
and join
and then i walk with them for the next
six months in their business
to help them chase their goals their
dreams figure out what their version of
success is
and then give them the tools to get
there so and that keeps you in
in the class you know if you're a
freshman or a sophomore or senior
there's not people joining every day and
leaving every day right exactly they're
in there
together and the community's part of the
aspect of it it is there's such power i
actually put them in buddies
and so it makes the big group feel
smaller and then i give them weekly
emails and curriculum on what you're
going to discuss with your buddy what
you're going to work on in your business
and we're all on the same track focusing
on the same things together we do
something really cool dave that i
actually started last year
out of covit and you know we were all
pivoting trying to figure out how to
make it work with covid one of the
things that
we came up with is a 250 challenge so
the cost of your membership is 244
so i came up with a 250 challenge and i
challenge them to make 250
in seven days and i give them a whole
list of ways to do this
we all rally the community gets a lot of
it i just get so excited you have people
posting the facebook group and what's so
cool is they do this the majority of
them do this and they've made their
membership feedback in seven days
and you've made roi in the first seven
days so it's just it's a really powerful
community but it's amazing to see
to see how when women get the help they
need when anyone
gets the help that they need they really
can do this thing they think you know
i'm not business minded i'm not cut out
for this
no you are you just need help like we
all do in any area of our lives that we
need help with
yeah i don't think a four-year-old gets
up and goes i'm not bicycle-minded
right right i wouldn't cut out for this
you're still gonna have to learn to ride
it baby
right that's how it works enrollment for
the academy is open as christie said
through thursday night april the 22nd
just about 24 more hours 48 more hours
and it's only open twice a year so you
don't want to miss your opportunity to
get in on this training the tools and
the support
uh and it's odd that it's uh you know
coming up on the week that is the
anniversary of the launch of the book so
uh join the academy at
ramseysolutions.com
academy and you can become a part of
this incredible community of women who
are
making money doing what they love
that's so important the book is also on
sale right now among our other books on
a 10
special at ramseysolutions.com store so
total money makeover business boutique
rachel's books ken's
books virtually all of our best-selling
books are in there on sale right now
with the 10
sale at ramseysolutions.com so be sure
and check that out as well but
the academy open through thursday night
april the 22nd shuts off at what time
thursday night eight o'clock
thursday night and um again ramsay
solutions dot com
slash academy and you'll get the help
from christy the one-on-one coaching the
uh
the community the challenges everything
you need to do to get
moving and get started in that business
or take your existing business and move
it to a different
level and it's a very unique community
and it's all about
changing everything the ramsey baby
steps community uh
kim little our manager of that community
uh
said if you want to be part of
like-minded people jump in on our
facebook group it's called the
ramsey baby steps community and
it's massive i mean several hundred
thousand people in there juliana says
i'm a single mom that's blessed to have
my mom
able to help me with my kids i'm in baby
step two it seems like it's going slow
i want to get a second job my mom is
supportive but i don't know how to
balance my
two kids that actually need my help i
know i need to get out of debt but i'm
torn
yeah this is one of those things that a
schedule is your friend
because if you're waiting until you have
time left over to
put money toward to work on a second job
or start a side business from home or
whatever that is
there's never time left over and there's
certainly never time left over when you
have young kids
and so i think that it can be in your
favor to come up the schedule whether
it's nap times
weekends what is can do you know maybe
it's from 7 to
10 p.m you bust it and try to get
creative with working from home or
freelancing or that type of thing with
some
flexibility but um the reality is you
have to have some type of schedule and
structure
otherwise you're gonna always feel like
you're coming from behind and so what is
what is realistic
but also a stretch goal to help you do
what you want to do to maybe speed this
up and get extra money
yeah and but also realistically all work
is not
profitable so you need to actually be
doing something that
makes money yeah i mean i would i take a
retail job and be away from my kids for
minimum wage
no right no you need to be doing
something that's two three times what
minimum wage is whether you're running
your own gig
doing something on the side i don't care
what it is you're doing but figure out
something that's going to pay
really well number one number two then
map it out and go okay this is only for
two years or this only for 18 months or
it's 19 months
and then i'll be out and then i can go
back to a regular schedule so if it pays
really good it's only for a reasonable
period of time you can lock it in
that'll give you the energy to do it
and the third piece of advice i've got
is work while everybody else is asleep
yeah yeah do your 4am reps what can you
do what can you write
what can you uh what can you you know
what orders can you fill
on ebay at four in the morning what uh
what
questions can you answer how can you
work when others sleep
because those kiddos aren't there you
know and you know the amount of time
people spend
that's supposed to be spent with their
kids in front of stupid television
you know you just take that out just
throw a brick through your tv you find
all kinds of hours
all kinds of hours in your life kristy
wright ramsey personality is my co-host
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
carly's in buffalo new york hey carly
how are you
i'm well dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so my husband and i recently
he was in an accident september we
recently received a settlement of a
hundred thousand dollars
wow is he okay not
uh yes actually like he is nearly
fully recovered so we got really lucky
on that one
wow sounds like it's a bad accident
it was a very bad accident he uh broke
his leg surgery
all of those and all those bills have
been paid
yeah it was covered yeah okay so in
addition you got a hundred thousand
clear and he's okay now
yes okay
all right and we're just not sure what
to do with it i know there's worse
problems to have but this feels kind of
burdensome like i don't want to mess it
up you know
like i feel like yeah uh
until we don't know i don't know i don't
know realistically
what to do i understand yeah you want to
be careful with it and wise well
we would apply it wherever you are on
the baby steps
so let's walk through that a little bit
do you have any debt other than your
home
no no home debt either no home debt okay
so
you're completely out of debt house and
everything what's your household income
uh about 33 a year 32 000
okay and um do you have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
yeah yeah good it's closer to nine
months good
good well you're in really good shape it
was lucky to have that
when he got hurt i bet i bet yeah you've
done a great job you're in great shape
congratulations
well um you know yes you could buy a
piece of real estate if you want to buy
that and pay cash for it
uh might be pushing it to find a hundred
thousand dollar property in buffalo i
don't know
uh things are going pretty high
yeah maybe you could but i would not
want you to go into debt for a rental
property i think that'd be a bad plan
and so if i'm in your shoes then that's
going to put me in mutual funds
probably and so and you need to take
your time and
understand that investment and
[Music]
you know move through the the process of
learning
on that before you actually make the
decision a good way to do that is to
connect
with one of our smart vester pros click
smart vester at daveramsey.com
ramseysolutions.com click smart vester
to make changes for me remember all this
crap oh it's a lot and um
yeah and anyway so yeah
ramseysolutions.com click smart vester
and it'll drop down a list of the smart
vester pros in your area that you can
uh connect with sit down in order for
them to get our endorsement they have to
have the heart of a teacher they have to
be willing and able to sit down and
teach you
because you should not put money in
something you don't understand and so
you know when you're doing something new
like investing it's it's intimidating
yeah that's why you need someone that
knows that specifically and i think some
people feel like oh i'm supposed to know
this
no even inside this building we use
investment professionals for our
investments because they are experts
that's what they do all day every day
but to your point you want to go to
someone that is trustworthy that's in
line with what we teach
because if not they could explain things
in a way that you don't understand and
you end up making some mistakes so you
want to go to someone you trust
yeah i just sat down and spent an hour
with um
our tax professional that does that
handles the ramsey
family oh god tax bill
and uh all the stuff and and you know
there's no way i'm gonna understand
freaking 10 billion words that the irs
wrote and know them all that's his job
but i do need to understand enough of it
that when i put my signature at the
bottom of that return
that i know what it's saying right i may
not know every little nuance and every
little thing perfectly but i need to get
the gist
of what we're doing so that i'm not just
blindly signing things and not
looking at them yeah exactly and that's
the same with investing it's the same
with doing your will
these are things that you don't have to
be you know you can put an expert in
your corner but
even somebody working on your car they
come in and go well you know it's going
to be eighteen hundred dollars to fix
the gym again
the jimmy gag and what the flips of
jimmy gag
you know you're gonna have to tell me
what the sparkle mana flaps are i mean i
i'm gonna have to get a figure start
over please
1800 bucks you just got my attention so
now i want to know what the flip's going
on here
and so you know you have to be taught
and and you don't blindly trust
anyone not because we're cynical right
but because it's our job to be
responsible for our decisions
where you get screwed on anything from
car repairs to investing anything else
it's when you don't understand
what you're doing and you just went oh
that's my guy he takes care of me it's
my guy
or you're too or you feel like you're
gonna look stupid if you ask questions
like this is your money it's a hundred
thousand dollars or whatever you're
doing it's your cards eighteen hundred
dollars
ask the question say well now what does
that word mean we
matt and i just sat down with our
investment guy a few months ago to kind
of do a reset on where we're going what
we're doing
and there were several things he said
that i go what does that word mean i
don't even know what that word like
and he explained it to me it's like okay
so don't be scared to ask questions this
is your money
that you're investing you can ask those
questions and really good people will
answer them in a way you can understand
an attorney a few years ago we were
working on not not litigation but on a
just a contractual situation
and he's like you know because i said so
and i went
hey dude you just got really confused
that that let me help you with this you
work for me
and i'm getting ready fire your butt try
again oh my god
because i said so what do you think you
are my dad he doesn't know you he didn't
know not to say that
bless his heart yeah right well he knows
now
irene is in san antonio hey irene what's
up
good afternoon mr ramsey thank you so
very much for taking my call
my pleasure how can we help i've been
listening to you for about five years
now and i followed all your steps so
i have totally eliminated all my credit
card debt i've eliminated all my student
loan debt i have two vehicles
i have absolutely no car payment i have
a hundred and five thousand dollars left
on my home
and my question is i want to go back to
school to pursue my phd
and i was wondering if that's a wise
thing for me to do
the reason why i want to do that is
because i've become
absolutely passionate about my field of
mental health
and so i want to teach on a university
level
very cool that's awesome first of all
congratulations
yeah paying off all that debt that's
amazing yeah thank you
i followed each and every step of mr
ramsey
and it completely transformed my life
over the past five years
you're amazing that's awesome so you're
paying cash for the phd
uh well what i'm going to do is i still
have forty thousand dollars left over in
grant money that i can put towards my
education
and then i'm going to take the rest of
it out of my
um out of my savings to pay off the rest
so
not that much but i have enough to cover
it so i'm not going
back into debt ever good good and you're
not dipping into the emergency fund to
do this
no absolutely not i have plenty left
over and actually making sure making
sure i understand what we're talking
about it's okay it's okay
okay i'm just making sure i understand
so you're gonna pay cash for a phd with
a grant and the excess savings
and it's what you want to do well why
wouldn't you do it
because i couldn't find it anywhere in
your book
why didn't you write a chapter on that
that's your fault yeah i i don't write a
lot about phds the only one i've gots in
d-u-m-b
so um
[Laughter]
education is not really one of the steps
other than pay cash for it
for your kids education and baby step
five and in any purchases you want to do
we're paying cash
for it and this is not a luxury it's
career advancement you're going to move
into a whole new phase of your life and
you've positioned yourself to do it this
is fabulous you want to do it
you have the money for it and it's
moving you in the direction of where you
want to go that checks all the boxes for
me irene you got it
touchdown thank you so much
i appreciate it i'm awesome appreciate
your asking our permission but i think
you're all right
that's right yeah you're a rock star
absolutely amazing
yeah that's uh uh and that is one you
know if you're gonna
teach at the university level then you
know that is permission to play this
table
that's table stakes that's right yeah
you got to have that to be to teach at
that level
and so and it's a wonderful field too
yeah
i mean we got john deloney around here
and he's got two phds he's fairly normal
most days most days some days
not so much most days yeah we keep him
fairly much in line james and kelly do
on his podcast but
it's a full-time job this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money steve is with us
in york pennsylvania hi steve how are
you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um the company i work for was bought
recently
and the pension i worked on for 12 years
or that i was given for 12 being there
for 12 years he offered me
three options one was to do a lump sum
or two to get a really small payment
starting like next month or three ways
to wait till i'm 65.
lump sum i just wanted to see what maybe
you would choose lump sum
it's a no-brainer and you roll it direct
transfer rollover
into an ira and there's no taxes on it
okay how much money is it uh 23
500 okay so let me tell you what happens
if you die
no not if you die when you die
that pension gives you zero
right yeah okay uh you die with twenty
three thousand dollars in your ira
you know what your estate has twenty
three thousand dollars
okay and you can invest it where it will
grow
faster and better than it will inside
that pension by putting it in good
mutual funds
so you're better while you're alive and
you're better while you die when you die
and so this is like what's known as a
no-brainer you do this immediately
always take the lump sum pension when
you can and run
okay make sense
yes it makes no sense okay thanks for
the call brother open phones
triple eight eight two five five two
two five the old pensions are just about
dead
yeah we don't get a ton of calls about
that but that's interesting because i
don't know the
i didn't know that that when you die you
don't get it in a pension i didn't know
that
is that any any any business any pension
any pension not 401k yeah 401k is yours
you own it
the pension's actually an asset of the
company it's not an asset of yours i
didn't realize 401k is your asset yeah
and so if company goes broke you can
lose your pension and
technically speaking um and you can't
lose your 401k if you're going to go
broke
but if you work for a company that
offers pension do you take it you don't
have a choice it's just you have to give
it
you just get it most companies like
78 of them have done away with pensions
there's just a few
mainly bigger ones it's an old
old-school thing and yeah
and some old governmental agencies and
things unions that kind of stuff
it's mainly things that just haven't
kept up is what amounts to that are
still doing pensions because the 401k is
much more advantageous to the user
sure so isn't this back in the same kind
of time frame when you know people
worked at the same company for 40 years
got a gold watch and a retirement party
and
yep that was enough and your pensions
your pension built up over time
and the the thing about the pension is
you don't put anything into it they put
into it you don't put anything into it
so
it doesn't cost you anything but what it
can cost you is your future by counting
on it and not having other other side
things to do stephanie's in rochester
new york hi stephanie welcome to the
ramsay show
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up in your world
um well my husband and i are trying to
decide if
um we should purchase a used vehicle or
if we should um keep a vehicle that
needs to be
repaired um
what baby step are you in we're in baby
step two
okay why would you what's the repair
uh it's it's like a issue
but it's like um leaking uh
fumes into the car and they said it's
gonna cost about eight hundred dollars
what's your car worth uh
i think it's about maybe like 2500
um with with meetings it's gonna take
eight hundred dollars to fix a muffler
um it's the repair shop i know what i
mean just an independent repair shop or
a muffler shop or the dealer
uh it's an independent like car repair
shop have you gotten other quotes
no okay that's first clue
um you always get more than one quote
when something seems weird because this
sounds a little weird
that sounds super expensive for a
muffler issue and i don't know cars
stephanie at all but that just sounds
expensive i thought so too
but i mean i might be missing part of it
yeah you could be
and we could be too but it's worth
checking on further because
it could be four hundred dollars which
changes the conversation doesn't it
yeah you wouldn't even been calling us
you to fix the car
800 puts it on the bubble so how much do
you have in savings
we have uh five thousand dollars right
now and we're expecting to get about
2500 back from our taxes
and i've kind of been nervous about
putting that toward our debt because of
our cars and not knowing
they're both kind of older higher
mileage cars
um and i was thinking you know within
the next year or so we might need to
replace them but i don't know if it's
smart to just
hold on to that money in case something
happens to the car or just
not worry about it pay down the debt and
then you know
well you're you're working your plan if
you're working our plan if you're
working our plan
you apply the money towards the debt
yeah
even if your car is like possibly going
to be breaking down
honey cars are all possibly going to be
breaking down
every one of them every car in this
parking lot is possibly breaking down
at any moment how much debt do you have
um
10 750 and what's your household income
about 42 000. so i mean with the money
that you have and the money that you're
expecting to get you just you can be
debt-free soon
yeah if you quit holding on to your
muffler money
[Laughter]
you know i i don't want you to die from
carbon monoxide poisoning so i do want
you to get this fixed
and get some more bids on it and find
out how dangerous it is or does it just
stink and so on
and you know so when we were going broke
and we were coming out of going broke
and trying to dig our way out doing what
you're doing and we were so broke we
couldn't pay attention and we were
scared just like you
are i was driving a car that the
transmission
main seal busted on it now let me tell
you what that means
that means the transmission fluid leaks
out of the transmission you know where
it goes
onto the muffler and you know what it
does it smokes
like a james bond car or something it's
put out a smoke screen behind me it
looked like a movie
and i had to put transmissional fluid in
the thing almost every three days just
to keep it running
but i just kept pouring transmission
fluid in it and smoking up the neighbors
and um and finally finally we got the
other side of it and i got the money to
fix the stupid car
after i got the debts cleaned up and uh
but i limped
through because i had to change my
direction
and that's what i want you to do i don't
want you to do something that's
dangerous the car i was driving wasn't
dangerous it just stunk
but uh and the neighbors thought it's
funny and it's a funny story now it
wasn't funny that it was embarrassing as
crap
but uh but i did drive that old beat up
thing and i got through
and now i drive whatever the flip i want
to drive because i've got the money now
and the reason i got the money is
i i didn't keep falling back into the
same trap my 1996 jeep grand cherokee
dave it's a piece of crap like a go-kart
it smells
well you probably hauled goats around in
it because you had goats
i actually did but that's not what
smells like no it stunk like that
that that oil smell like a go-kart like
if you were at the go-kart races
i prayed that thing back to life more
times than i can
count like great parade it back to life
cars don't have a soul
that didn't happen that didn't happen
you cannot lay hands on lazarus the
cheap
well the jeep came back to life you take
that up with god himself
that jeep came back to life when i
prayed
but you're right it's like it's
embarrassing for a season and then you
get through that season and she's not
even that far i mean we're talking 7500
she's so close yeah she's 7 500 bucks
and out of 10 000 and just boom you're
going to be right there
we can see this but you're gonna have to
change your focus on what what what do
you believe in
what do you believe is gonna take you to
the next five years keeping this money
in the account limping along with these
old cars and and limping out of that
or busting through kiddo our suggestion
is
bust through you're gonna make a
decision now what do you believe in
and all of us let me tell you for a
whole bunch of us a whole bunch of you
listening
that are out of debt and have become
everyday millionaires me and christy
we've all driven that crappy car that
was so crappy that you had to give it a
name
old blue bertha whatever her name was
i don't know why they get female names
not the david nobody nobody names it
george hey kiddies they always give them
negative female names henrietta i don't
know
but you got to give them a name that uh
you know
and if you if you hadn't been through
that then you don't know what that poor
lady's facing but we're with you
stephanie you can do this
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
dawn is in indianapolis hi dawn how are
you
i'm blessed dave thank you thank you how
can we help
i called because my four children
just inherited 187 thousand dollars each
from a life insurance policy that i took
out on their dad
when i was married to him 13 years ago
and i need to thank you dave because
we feel so blessed today that i did what
you said in the financial peace class
that i took
back then we put policies in place and
their dad just died a month ago
and now my kids have have this money in
hand from the life insurance company
it's a lot of money
per kid and we want to know how you
would invite them what
what should they do if they're only 25
years old
20 18 and 16 and you can only put like a
6 000 in a ross every year so i just
we're here to ask you your advice
and we want to just thank you you've
blessed us
i'm sorry for your loss all of you so it
was your ex
right yeah yeah we did divorce eight
years ago but 13 years ago when we were
together we did this
right that's what i thought i understood
you to say okay
well i think different age kids will
have different needs a 16 year old has a
different need than a 30 year old
the 30 year old we're just going to
apply it on the baby steps wherever they
okay so they have any debt you apply to
debt if they don't have if they got the
only debt make sure the emergency fund's
in place
15 of your income going towards
retirement kids college is five
and six is pay off the house so we roll
that money up that list until it runs
out
okay does that make sense yes yes
okay and really i would do that you said
16 was the youngest and there was an 18
25 maybe
it was 25 20 18 and 16. what's the 20
year old
the 20 year old what is he doing well
yeah
um we we don't know yet other than i've
advised them that they need to set
up i mean what's his life what's he
doing with his life is he in school
is he working he he spent the past year
and a half taking care of his sick dad
so now he has to find his life he does
have a two-year degree
but yeah he doesn't he's been taking
care of his dad while he was terminally
ill
okay well i would put him in the 16 year
old and
uh you know make sure they're reading
through ken coleman's stuff on career
and christy's stuff and you know just
get get a handle on who they are
and so some of this money there's a
probability will be used for education
as a matter of fact i might park it all
just to the side and something really
simple
for the two youngest ones until we
ascertain
what educational needs they have and so
16 year old says i want to go to college
i want to go to a four-year school
then we make sure that the four-year
school room board books
tuition is under 187 000 for four years
otherwise you picked the wrong school
sure
okay and yeah they're more community
they're community college kids
yeah and you know get the first two
years out of the way and then go move
and take two more years at the
at the you know in-state university and
he'll have some money left over
but i would just make sure we use this
money to get them the education to start
their lives the other
older ones have already started their
lives and you just applied to the baby
steps i think do you think see something
else
yeah i was just wondering dave when
you're going through that type of a loss
for these kids they've lost their dad
is there any type of waiting period it
may be different because they're kids or
even if someone's older is there any
kind of waiting periods like let's not
decide to do anything with it for a
period until
a little bit of the initial grieving is
over
where it's like i don't know i just can
you think clearly when you lost your dad
a month ago
you know well exactly yeah i mean it's
it's good to park it for a little while
yeah and let it sit the 16 and 18 year
old are gonna have to let it sit anyway
yeah because they're gonna have to make
some decisions that are gonna take more
than 30
seconds i mean you're going to sit down
and think about what you want to do
what studies are involved in what it is
you want to do where you're going to get
your
education and then you map out what
that's going to cost and begin to apply
the 187 towards that
as far as the baby steps goes yeah
before you start paying off
but i mean i i don't know that a 30 year
old losing their dad
can't uh decide to pay off their car
with this money
25 is the oldest right dawn no yes she's
25
25 is the oldest okay so even that i'm
like so is she
married or kids or she is married and
they just had their first baby two weeks
ago
okay so that one's yeah they probably
have a pretty traditional set of baby
steps to walk
right and i probably can't give them
much advice because they're married
right yeah yeah right well it's
completely up to them but if
if they were to call me and ask me what
i would tell them to do
would be to work up the baby steps in
other words pay off your debts make sure
you have an emergency fund in place
make sure you get 15 going into
retirement make sure the new baby has a
college fund
uh and you know then pay off your house
do they own a house
they do okay yeah and i suspect that
those steps will use up 187.
okay what about so the 18 year old
college is already taken care of
so she wants to know what to do with it
besides puts them in a rock
how's her college um
we've already fully funded that and
she's got three years left it's fully
funded
uh she's room and board
yeah i mean she she she drives back and
forth to school it's a four-year school
and she drives she lives at home with me
still
all right um you know that
you do not have to get fancy uh you know
what i would do is keep it very simple
and very calm until you get out of
school
uh and to christie's point let's not try
to be professional investors at 18 years
old when you just lost your dad
so you don't you don't have to you
haven't done something wrong
if you don't suddenly become a highly
seasoned
uh professional investing person you
know so
if if she wants to sit down in the next
few weeks as her as girl's brains
start to some of the fog of grief starts
to clear if she wants to sit down with a
smartvestor pro and begin to look at
what she could do with investing that's
fine but
when she finishes school 16 year old
finishes school
with whatever money is invested whatever
money's left over
that's probably going to set up their
adult life really well
they might pay cash for a house in
indianapolis and indianapolis for that
if they're careful uh or they might you
know move to another city or they might
do a lot of different things it gives
it gives them some flexibility it's not
a millionaire
it's 187 and that's a lot of money in
one way
but in another way you can kind of go
like it's all over it's not over
this just gives you a boost this is not
the rocket it's a booster shot
but for those for those younger ones
especially the ones that don't own homes
yet
i mean you make a great point because
that could buy them a house
in cash out of the gate they never have
a mortgage they are completely set up
for the rest of their lives they never
owe
debt of any kind and that would
drastically change
their financial lives if they started
that would be a great
legacy for uh uh for her for their dad
you know that the dad literally with
this life insurance might change the
family tree
um what what a cool you know what a cool
side note to a
to a horrible situation um
and that's what life insurance always is
it's always a cool side note to a
horrible situation yeah
you know uh we had a young lady out of
south carolina that we've videoed for
some of the financial peace classes that
um you know a brand new baby
and they're in their 20s and he just
it was just a freak thing he's had a
stroke or something and just died
i mean but they had you know he had a
bazillion dollars in life insurance and
it
um you know obviously this a young
mother that had lost her husband is
horrible
and this baby really never really knew
his dad and
um it was a horrible horrible thing
uh but the good side note is that she
never has to work
well i'm curious about this life
insurance topic what do you think keeps
people from getting it
is it fear of talking about such a
horrible thing like death
is it just they're too busy they never
get around to it like it's not a fun
thing to talk about we can all
acknowledge that
but in a situation like this it's one of
those things that like you have to have
it
well it's in the category of smart
things to do that give you no immediate
feedback
yeah and you know if it's if i'm doing
something retirement why don't people
say for retirement what they say for the
kids college because 20 years off
right and you know thank god it's friday
oh god it's monday right you know and
people are short-term
uh vision windows and so they don't have
any vision in other words and where
there is no vision that people perish
and so
when you look out in the future and you
see you know this is what's coming and
i got to get ready for it that's called
maturity yeah but we have a vastly
immature culture
and so yeah you need wills you need life
insurance
you need retirement planning you need
kids college but these
delayed pleasure things are all
that they're all a sign of maturity
toward amounts to
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
pm
the paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice christie
wright ramsey personality is here to do
this show because apparently i can't
and so we're here she's here to co-host
with me and i'm going to stumble through
and we're going to pull this off and
we're here to help you with your life
and with your money
it's what we do the phone number is free
and some say the advice is worth what
you pay for it
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two two five steve's with us in
nashville hey steve
welcome to the ramsey show thank you
dave and thank you so very much for
taking my call
sir my pleasure how can i help and good
evening also to christy
thanks dave i am currently
me my wife my mother and my son are on
a level term insurance policy you were
talking about life insurance while ago
and this fits into it but
um currently my
agent wants a couple of us to switch
over to a whole life
i bet he does yeah yeah and uh i wanted
to ask you
why first of all my mother is she's
she's insured permanently because of her
age
when i fixed her up on a level term she
she went through the two-year probation
time and
she's fine my son is 30 years old
they want him to swap over and of course
i'm 57 they want me to
my wife is on a 10-year level term her
age she's 66 and
um they're telling me it's going to be
very difficult for her to get rewritten
when hers expires in five years
how's your money situation i'm i'm okay
what's happening i'm certainly not
self-insured today
okay how how you're in your 50s
how much nest egg do you have uh
about 50. okay and how much debt do you
have
i do have some debt um
my home mostly it's about 60 00.
not much okay that's good and what are
you doing towards retirement from this
point forward
i'm not at this point i've not
actually got a retirement plan in place
okay
well obviously you're going to need to
do that right okay right yes sure
okay and uh does your wife work outside
the home
no sir she's disabled and what do you
make
around 50 a year okay so the purpose
of life insurance is to make sure
that the people left behind who are
counting on the person's income
are taken care of correct
if god forbid your wife were to pass
away
mathematically you would be just fine
right because you're not dependent upon
her correct to
financially move forward now i'm not
talking about your heart wouldn't be
broken i'm not talking about we wouldn't
cry
i'm not talking about those kinds of
things okay i'm just saying
mathematically
and this is the this is the discussion
of life insurance is the math
part okay and so if we
cancel her life insurance when it
goes up it's not that big a deal
okay so i wouldn't continue to buy life
insurance on her
once it goes up so if it you know her
term
runs out or you said she had a 10-year
term when that runs out
i would just drop it you see why
yes sir okay now in your case
you're gonna need life insurance to take
care of her until you get this nest egg
built
you're 57 you're out of debt except your
home
time to get with saving some money
investing some money pretty aggressively
for the next
uh 10 years or so right yes sir
and let's pretend that you had uh 300
000
in your investments and you get your
house paid off
ten years from today and that's all very
possible if you start concentrating
would you agree with me
agree okay and you die
she has three hundred thousand dollars a
paid for house and no kids at home
i think she'll be okay yes sir so we're
working towards
self-insurance and in the meantime we
prop it up with
life insurance you follow the concept
yes sir
see the only thing whole life is good
for is to make sure your agent gets a
commission through your whole life
that's what it's for it's the kind of
encouragement
yeah the and the the premiums are 10
times to 20 times more expensive
for the same amount of life insurance
okay
but it's all based on the premise that
you're not gonna do anything to get
yourself ready to not need life
insurance
okay so we took care of you two now
let's talk about mom how old's mom
mom is about 85. and um
anybody depending on her income to eat
no there's not
okay so why is that she's got life
insurance
it's just back when i lost dad dave
uh he did not have insurance and it was
a little difficult on the family to take
care of all the arrangements
now does your mom have any money she's
she's uh
not really she got twenty thousand
dollars
no sure sure she's on a fixed income
okay
so she doesn't have any lives with she
lives with my fam
not me but with my other family okay so
we need enough to bury her
yes sir but that's all we really need
that's what i have on her
okay so you have a very small policy on
her and it's term
it is term dave uh and and what we
started with her
remember she has some uh some underlying
issues
and they wanted to go with the two-year
uh probation i started with her and and
that elapsed and she's
he told me just the other day i met with
him he said she's insured for life
because i'm assuming because of her age
that's strange okay well it's probably
not that expensive a policy though
because it's not covering the 10 or 20
000 bucks right
it's really not though so it's not an
issue so
we got three of the four done now your
son is 30
and what he needs to do is work the baby
steps get out of debt have an emergency
fund
and 20 years from today you know not
need insurance because he paid off his
house in 15 years
and because he's got 700 800 000 in his
401k and his kids are grown and gone 20
years from today
he needs a 20-year level term and he
doesn't need to use your guy because
your guy's a whole life guy
you guys are paying too much for the
stinking term but it's probably too
expensive for you to move
now but it's not for your son he needs
to go to zanderinsurance.com
and get a quote and he'll probably find
his term insurance is half what you guys
are paying for it
really yeah i i'm guessing i'm not
allowed to tell you who he's
insured i don't care who's he with farm
bureau okay
farm bureau is a wonderful company for
car insurance
and homeowners insurance yes their term
prices are
absolutely ludicrous really
yeah but they're great people i got
friends that work there
i mean i really like the company but you
don't buy life insurance there it's not
they're really good though for car
insurance terms their car insurance
service
i've been hit by people that had farm
bureau and i get they they take care of
the car i mean they're just they're
wonderful
you know and um i i'm i'm a fan
of the company but don't buy a term
there no it's a bad idea don't buy any
life insurance there it's just too
expensive because they're
they're not really designed to be in
that business that's like something they
added on to their catalog later
and they thought well we make a lot of
money doing this and your guy's not a
bad guy
he's just trained by those whole life
guys and so he just
doesn't know what the flippy's doing and
that's in this particular subject
so you got to stay away from people
pushing cash value nobody believes in
this whole life stuff
except people that sell it everybody
else in the financial world knows and
understands and says
no way this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
five years ago this week she launched a
book that was number one
called business boutique equipping women
to make money doing what they love
the follow-up to that is the business
boutique academy
that helps you uh build your business
build your side hustle
start a business uh and it's for
equipping women to make money doing what
they love
we only allow you to join the academy
twice a year it's closed
enrollment because we want everybody to
be in groups that have the
same experience as they go through so
enrollment is
open right now for a limited time until
thursday
evening this coming thursday april the
22nd so don't miss your opportunity to
get in on the training
you can join at uh join the academy at
ramseysolutions.com
academy now the other thing we want you
to know is we've got the ramsey
solutions website
up now so ramseysolutions.com is now
your destination site for all things
ramsey and that includes
all things christy wright john deloney
rachel cruz
anthony o'neal and whoever i'm leaving
ken coleman i can't remember who i'm
here for you yeah that's it
that's good you're going to carry this i
knew you were
good-looking site the site is much more
uh it's much easier to navigate and find
what you're looking for
you don't have to go on a wild goose
chase all the time a ton of great
resources a ton of tools there
a ton of free articles on just about
every subject where it comes to
transforming your life
go to ramseysolutions.com and check out
the new site it has been launched for
about a month and it is
all the feedback all the feedback has
been positive no one went where'd
daveramsey.com go because nobody
cared but me except you
where'd my name go where's my name not
really all right alicia's in decatur
indiana
hi alicia how are you hi dave hi christy
hi um thanks for taking my call
um my husband and i are having kind of a
dilemma
on what to do with an inherited ira
um a little back story is we've been
date-ish for
quite a while and at the beginning of
november we decided that we were going
to go full in and you know pay off all
of our debt so we had some more freedom
well since then we paid off twenty eight
thousand dollars worth of debt
good and the only thing um
well the only thing we have left is my
student loan debt
good so it's um right around forty 40 41
000
and how much was the inherited ira 88
thousand is what it is
yes pay off your student loan out of
that you're gonna have to you're gonna
have to cash out the inherited ira
over the period of the next few years
anyway that's the law
and you're going to pay taxes on it as
it comes out no penalties
and you might as well pay your taxes now
and be debt-free
yeah it's just a security blanket for me
i guess it's not a security blanket you
have a student loan debt
yeah that's true you have a security
blanket with an axe hanging over your
head
that's true probably makes sense so it's
not very secure
you know no no no and you know be
debt-free
listen here's the thing when you got all
geared up and you paid off 28 000 since
november
the reason you did that was you came to
believe
that the shortest distance between where
you are and wealth and financial
stability
is to get your butt out of debt right
true nothing's changed yeah
just stay the course take the hit
because not because it's not a hit it's
not a hit it's an advancement
when you see it as a hit you feel like
you're losing money you're taking that
money and you're applying it to the debt
this is a move
forward so we gotta we gotta reframe
that in your mind when you see that as a
hit
it feels like it feels hard to do let me
give you let me give you an example on
this you took the hit when you took out
the student loan
when you pay it off you admit it
yeah when you buy a car that's 30 000
when you buy a car that's 30 000
and it goes down to 20 000 and you sell
it
people say oh i took the hit no you you
already
got the hit you already lost ten
thousand dollars
when you sell the car you just admit it
yeah that's all it is it doesn't change
it doesn't change the reality
it just makes you face the emotions of
this student loan was a stupid butt idea
well it's okay we've all done stupid
butt stuff
i made a living doing it kiddo
all right you're gonna be all right
you're doing good i'm proud of you you
know
the interesting term she used security
blanket made me think of that call in
the last hour where they
they had 7 500 had a debt of 10 000 but
didn't want to paid off because it was
that same concept of like this makes me
feel safe because i have this money here
it's an illusion it's an illusion and
it's like the idea that that is keeping
you safe and it's somehow going to be a
move backwards to pay off the debt
no no that is the move forward and you
know what that
that does bring up a thing too this idea
that the enemy of the best
is not the worst yeah the enemy the best
is
okay kind of in the middle if you can
just sit in the ugly middle and be
comfortable
you got no reason to bust into
excellence you've got no reason to bust
into the exit and it's familiar
it makes me think of in financial peace
university which i when i took this
years ago
you talk about the credit cards like oh
no not this last one i'm so attached to
it
and there's an emotional attachment we
have these ideas in our head that even
if they're not accurate mathematically
at all about what it's going to do for
us financially
we get attached oh i've got to hang on
to the savings even though i have all
this debt and i'm paying all this
interest
because it makes me feel safe that's not
that's not a reality
me going broke i had an advantage
i didn't have a choice yeah yeah you
were forced i'm sitting there
in the poop and i gotta go i gotta get
up out of this
because it wasn't comfortable right but
if you're sitting there and you kind of
feel comfortable it gives you this
that that's where the enemy of the best
is not the worst i was at the worst
yeah and i knew it and i didn't want to
be there anymore i was motivated to get
my butt out of there right
you know but when everything's just kind
of okay and i got my little ten thousand
dollars and
i got my little eighty-eight thousand
dollars and i'm okay and that your
your brain just whines like that mine
does it too on other things
yeah it's like you know i'm not fat
enough that i'm gonna die
so i don't do anything about my fat you
know you know what i mean but
but if the doc came in and went you're
morbidly obese you're about to die
of a heart attack fat man then i would
go do something about it sure but my
brain is like
my level of fat i'm kind of in the
middle you know until until i hit covet
and then i just got
big as a dadgum house and i had to go so
i've lost 37 pounds y'all shut up all
right but
uh because i needed to because i was
going to turn in the michelin man but
um but the you know but you know it's
the same thing isn't it
any area of our life if it's if you can
hit that
that mediocre middle that's a danger
zone you're comfortable
it's a danger zone and it gives you the
illusion that you're doing better than
you are
because you've got this security blanket
whatever your security blanket is it's
like i'm okay
i'm doing okay you don't have that
motivation that you're talking about
like things are bad i have to change
something
what did you oh your quote i love so
much you can wander into debt you cannot
wander out
yeah you got to get fired up if you're
going to do something you've got to get
yourself
on anything if you're going to transform
your life it's going to involve the most
painful of all emotions and that's
embracing change stepping face long
into change intentionally i'm going to
step up
i'm going to bust into this thing and i
don't care if it's
you know your marriage is just kind of
instead of having an awesome marriage
you know you gotta you gotta go
something's gotta give
i gotta change something you know it's
like man i tell you the kids man
you know your kids are out of control
when you go that's it
that's it you know my mama used to say
the worm has turned
i don't even know what that meant except
the beatings were about to begin
you know but the uh uh turned out of
shakespeare who knew mom
knew shakespeare but um but you know all
that was was she had reached the end of
her rope you know yeah
the little grand babies the little girls
denise's and rachel's little girls are
over at the house of the night and
they're jumping bed to bed to bed to bed
and i'm trying to get them in bed and
sharon's got the boys in other room
putting them down i'm sitting in the
rocking chair and i'm just girls sit
down
girls lay down girls stop it and they're
just getting more and more wound up
and one of them says papa dave's getting
frustrated
yeah it's coming mama mama agreed
she said when mama gets frustrated it
ain't good
so that means my daughter's doing a good
job i like that
that's right so i said girls you're
gonna have to lay down
but i mean the worm has turned you have
to have this moment in your life where
you say
enough i've had it and sometimes being
in the comfortable middle doesn't
doesn't make you do that that's true and
you have to manufacture that in your
emotions and just decide
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america christy
wright ramsey personality is my co-host
today
i'm dave ramsey your host this is the
ramsey show we talk about everything
having to do with your life
back in the day it was me getting you
out of debt which we still will help you
do
but the whole purpose of that is for you
to have a better life christy talks
about having a better life by having
more confidence and avoiding fear and
having balance in your life
and speaks all over america to companies
and
churches and writes a uh devotional that
just came out that was a best-selling
book which we didn't know devotionals
could be best sellers i was something we
learned something that's good that's
cool you proved it
well it was the first one we get to put
it out as a company which was awesome so
we proved the idea
well and yeah and i also i mean i didn't
know there was like a devotional
bestseller list but there is
and just learned something but it's cool
because you made it and um
it's it's a great great uh read and uh
40 days
to get back to you yep and uh you've
gone through it a couple times with
folks on instagram are you gonna do that
again well i'm actually in the middle of
it right now
because and this is interesting i don't
know if we've talked about this dave but
i chose the number 40 because it's a
biblical number sure and it's a great uh
non-intimidating length of time for
someone to go through
but the one of the instances of 40 in
the bible was the 40 days that jesus
appeared to people
after his resurrection so starting we're
in that period following easter that's
what we're doing so i started on monday
after easter
on day one and we're tracking so today
is day fifteen i believe
okay day twenty day stream day fifteen
or sixteen and so i'm walking through it
right now actually so
it's amazing how quickly these uh easter
or christmas gets in your rear view
mirror
was only 15 days ago i know i know and
then mother's day is coming up so it's
kind of nice in between eastern mother's
day
to walk through this women's devotional
that i've written and um and it's been
cool we've been
you're doing it on instagram yeah okay
christy be right be right yep just going
live once a week and walking through
kind of having a discussion um you know
and just seeking god i guess
the whole premise was can you imagine
how people after jesus rose
how once the word had spread that he was
appearing on the earth how people were
looking for him right they're like i
mean i've heard he's walking around and
appearing
they must have been really looking for
him with a new level of intensity and so
that's the heart behind this is let's
look for god for the next 40 days
together do this pretty cool all right
carol is with us in los angeles hi carol
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how you doing great how can we
help
okay so um i spent the past 10 years
taking care of my mom
and she passed away last year and i was
wondering if i should
sell her house and buy a condo in a
neighboring state
wow what an emotional thing
you've been in this home and so you've
been this angel
a blessing to her for a decade of your
life
yeah i i didn't work or anything i took
care of her
i take it you're single yes i am and
what's the house worth
a house is worth i have to have it
appraised because of probate but it's
right now the low end and what the
neighbor's going it's like 850 thousand
yeah okay and you're the sole heir i
assume
yes i am okay uh and
how are the rest of your finances what
are you gonna do for a career now
i don't know i was thinking of maybe
doing um things i've kind of dreamed
about working on since i was a kid
like writing and then i got into um
coding when i was in college and that
was kind of my day job before i started
taking care of my mom
so i thought i would do like some
independent projects like
um making video games and things like
that
my coding so when did she pass
she passed away last april actually so
what have you been eating on for the
last year what are you using for money
um my best friend she um has been paying
me to take care of her kids
to watch them because you know they have
to stay home because of copay so you've
had
you've had a nanny or a governess gig
yeah
okay all right
well um
it sounds to me like you're someone
that's given your life away for a while
and
it's time for you to live a part of this
next section for you
yeah what are you thinking christie yeah
the thing that the thing that jumped out
to me even in the question and i don't
you know as far as the house i don't
i don't know but i think i think what
you need right now carol is just
community
around you just to some people to help
you rediscover
uh who you are and what you want to do
in this new season i would definitely
love for you stay on the phone we can
send you a copy of my devotional that's
what we talked about 40 days to get back
to you to figure out who you are in this
new season
and and even um i'd love to invite you
to be a part of the academy where we can
kind of
put our arms around you as you discover
maybe there is something you can do
on your own it's a side business or
small business or freelance whether it's
coding or
something else writing yeah we can we
can walk with you in this next new
season and i'd love i'd love to do that
so
we can definitely um give you those
things to help you in this transition
but as far as the house i mean
i want to uh i don't know simultaneously
applaud you
for how you've served your mom and now
how you're serving this family
um and at the same time for doing that i
i want to encourage you in this next you
do the right thing
in this next season i don't want you to
define yourself
by how you've given yourself away okay
in the next season i want you to do some
things for carol
it's your turn and that's not selfish
it's just that you put some of your
dreams desires wishes on the shelf
for other people and i don't want you to
by default sign up for another season of
that
yeah it's time for you and your mom
would want you to go on and do the next
thing
yeah because she she did say that like
towards she was like you know maybe it
would be better if she wasn't here
and i could well we don't want that
don't say that that's not what we're
talking about but i mean but we are
saying that you know
you've had a year since her passing to
to grieve
and to reset your mind uh yes i'm
selling this house
not necessarily because i'm selling the
house but because it represents the past
that's good yeah i grew up in this house
yeah it's all about the past
and the past is in the past it has
passed
and so let's you know let's say all
right let's pretend we're 18 years old
and the world
is a white board and we have a million
dollars
what could we do anything we want it
right i mean there's nobody telling us
what to do there's nobody guiding us
we can do anything we want to do because
that's exactly where you are
only you're not 18. yeah and that can be
intimidating but it can also be exciting
it should be it should be both yeah
this kind of a journey is exhilarating
because it's parts of it are unknown
but yeah i'm selling it i'm moving as i
start to
uh figure out what my next chapter is
i'll know where to buy
in the meantime i might just put this
money in the bank and i might go
i don't know uh whatever it is you've
always wanted to do
backpack the appalachian trail i don't
know rent travel yeah
i don't have any idea but i mean
whatever it is your your thing is
you've had you got a pretty good number
of things on the dusty shelf
get them off and but blow the dust off
of them and sell the house
and let's get going and just i just want
to encourage you to do that and
encourage you to say that that does not
make you a bad person you've been a
saint you've been an angel
and the proper way to
uh uh to to continue to serve is to find
your best self
in this next phase and that's not
necessarily to give yourself away
yeah uh so hang on we'll have kelly pick
up we're going to send you a copy of the
christy's devotional and going to give
her business boutique academy yeah yeah
so we're going to
sign you up for both and it's on open
enrollment right now
and so we'll sign you up for both and
get you going and it's our gift to you
to help you live this next phase yep
this next
season for you so um but again this has
nothing to do with the value of the
house the location of the house
it's not a financial decision it's a an
emotional a fresh start
fresh start decision yeah that's a good
one it's the white board
man what a cool situation though yeah
yeah i mean how many people would
go i have no nothing binding me
i don't have anything holding me back i
can i don't she's not married she
doesn't have kids
she doesn't have a job that's weighing
her down
she doesn't have and she's got a million
dollars and that's where you go what do
you want to do and that can be one of
the hardest questions to answer
what do you want i'm intimidating his
crowd yeah what do you want to do you
can do anything
yeah it's going to take take some time
to for you to figure that out i think
yeah
go ahead and send her proximity
principle for by ken coleman too let's
see if we can
i want to interfere in our life here in
the best way
in the best papa dave kind of way
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're answering your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five james
is in evansville indiana hi james how
are you
hi dave pretty good good what's up
i have a college planning question
my wife and i have five young daughters
ages 10 to 13 months and
we have uh five 529 plans
and are contributing the max for the
tax incentive of 2500
we're now in a point in our life where
we could be applying more
but what does that look like for uh
[Music]
having five kids
and hearing about eight years
uh having one go off to college
yeah well about five years no no no
eight years i'm
not yeah yeah okay
all right um no it's more like thirteen
there it is ten years i'm sorry i wrote
i couldn't try and look at these numbers
i wrote it down i couldn't find them
uh all right so
you know what what it amounts to is you
need to be putting in more
for the 10 year old than you do the 13
month old
because the 13 month old's got a lot of
time to grow in that account
and so um who have you got your 529s
with
you got an advisor yes yes i haven't
we have an advisor uh we've got about 17
000
that it's grown right now for that
ten-year-old no no no ten-year-old okay
what i would do is sit down with the
advisor and make sure that the money is
invested in the 529 in good growth stock
mutual funds that have a good track
record first
if it is then i would ask them to
add to tell you okay in order for the 18
the 10 year old in eight years to have x
number of dollars what have we got to
add to that account
in order for the next one to add you
know in so many years what have we got
to add to that account and it might end
up that you're putting
i'll just make up numbers you might end
up putting three thousand dollars uh
or four thousand dollars in the ten year
olds and you might end up putting five
hundred dollars in the
13 month old and they'll end up with the
same amount
okay because you got started later on
the 10 year old
yeah and so you didn't have as many
years for the money to grow
so uh it's um
it's kind of like life equal
is not fair
yeah they've already been told that yeah
equals not fair fair is not equal
and so uh you know if you've got a
special needs little brother little
sister we're going to give more money
and make sure that that
child is taken care of equal is not fair
fair is not equal
is there fair is what you have at the
county
is there a magic sauce for
for about what should be put in uh
to be able to fully fund them uh
well what you need to do is just
determine what your goal is uh your goal
amount and you say okay
as an example they're going to go to
in-state schools they're in evansville
indiana they're going to go to the
university of indiana
okay our indiana university all right
and you call them and go what's it cost
to go there
and uh what are your projections on your
tuition uh eight years from today
and they tell you it's gonna take a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to go
there
with room and board four years eight
years from now
and uh for four years and i'm making up
numbers i don't know okay
today today tuition is about ten
thousand dollars plus room and board
per year for an in-state school average
nationally and so you're probably going
to find somewhere around the ten
thousand dollar number
per year so that's 40 000 plus if
they're going to stay in a dorm and eat
okay so i'm gonna guess and say they can
go for 100 grand eight years from now
that's maybe 125 but you know you can
actually get the number from the
university
bother them a little bit or wherever you
think you want them to go to school and
then you can back into the actual goal
with your advisor they can put it into a
financial calculator and go okay in
order to do that
you need to save twenty six hundred and
forty two dollars a month or
twenty six hundred forty two dollars a
year they can tell you exactly what
you need to do in order to get there
once you have that goal and you have the
time period it's a financial calculation
at that point it's a
math it's a math formula it goes into a
financial calculator and you can back
into it so
but you need a target and not just so
far your target has been
we want to save for college it was very
vague but if you really want to do it
perfectly and you want to know when
you're done this is how we did it
okay what we did was we said we wanted i
want a hundred thousand dollars per kid
and i backed it out for a four-year-old
and i said in order to do that today i
need x
in there and i just i had made some
money that year and i just put x in
there and then i was done
that account was over i never added to
it again never had to i put enough in
there that it was going to grow
for the four-year-old in 14 years to
this much so when daniel ramsey got
ready to go to school
there was a hundred thousand in there
for him you know and it was ready to go
and we just picked out a number but uh
you need to if you want to
be really nerdy about it and i do
recommend that if you know what your
goal is you can back into your numbers
exactly
i've got a question about the
scholarship side of things because i
know with 529's like it's specifically
for school
if you save all this money and then your
kids are just get a ton of scholarships
what do they do with that money 100 of
what they get in scholarships can be
removed tax-free
you know what now if they get if you got
a hundred thousand dollars and then you
get forty thousand dollars in
scholarships you can take forty thousand
dollars out and
oh really wow yeah you just had to prove
that you just have to prove the
scholarships if you're audited
i didn't know that so you can remove it
and you've had tax-free
growth on your money in a 529 wow that's
cool it's wonderful so
incentivizes the child to get
scholarships and that type of thing and
no they got money
free money totally okay great yeah i
mean they go buy a house with it when
they get out of college
i didn't realize that's a pretty cool
thing you're setting a millionaire stuff
here yeah
setting your kid up to be a millionaire
before they're 30. because if they come
out of school with a hundred thousand
bucks or 150
000 bucks and no student loan debt and
they go get a job making 70 or whatever
they're making these days right doing
whatever
yeah oh my gosh i mean you know 22 years
old you're making that and you've got
zero debt and you already have a paid
for house
ding ding you're a millionaire by the
time you're 30. yeah
and uh the number i mean it's just
compound interest it's just running the
math out
and so what he's doing there the way
he's planning i mean he's thinking about
it he got a little baby
13 months and going this baby's gonna go
to college but if once you dial all that
in
and then you see what the the next layer
of effect of that is and the next layer
of that effect
yeah it gets rowdy right and when we
talk about you changed your family tree
you
really did change your family tree it's
real it really happened taylor's in
denver
hey taylor how can we help hey how you
doing dave
better than i deserve what's up
so i have a dilemma i'm currently in
denver colorado and i'm working at a
great job
i make about ninety thousand dollars a
year it's a contract position
and uh they told me already that they'd
like to extend it at the beginning of
the new year for another year
but my last job has now invited me to
come back and join them
for a substantial raise they'd like to
offer me a hundred and sixty thousand
dollars
to move to orlando florida and
um work there for eight months until the
end of the year
and then the position will be over with
my question is
should i stay in colorado knowing that i
have
a good paying job and it'll last a good
long while
or should i go to florida for the
additional money
which is roughly about 3 000 i'm sorry
three times
my take-home pay each month here in
colorado
well no it's not three times 90 times
three is not 160.
what do you do for a living so yeah
with my um it's about 9 000 take-home
pay for the job in
orlando florida and about five thousand
three hundred dollars take home pay for
the job in denver
okay that's not even double it's not
five times as much
okay you tell me you don't do math for a
living okay what do you do i don't do
math really and i do construction thank
god
okay what kind of construction are you
doing
i do 5g fiber optic construction good
for you
okay i get it and so um how old are you
i'm 24 years old what do you want to be
doing when you're 34
i want to be running my own
telecommunications business which one of
these two decisions takes you their best
i think they both i think they both take
each one takes
[Music]
because your business is so you are a
contract to contract to contract anyway
you guys jump from job to job anyway in
your world don't you
yes sir all right jump drop the job and
take the money
unless you just don't like orlando i
would be
it's an adventure dude you're 24 go make
some money that's my opinion yeah
you're young do it while you can this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast it's a quick hit of
advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five matthew starts off this
hour in indianapolis hi matthew how are
you
i'm doing well dave how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
so i'm 22 years old i make about eighty
thousand dollars a year before bonuses
i have twenty thousand in cash and then
about fifty thousand i have in etfs and
mutuals
i'm getting ready to buy my first house
right now i know the housing market is
crazy
um my main question is is what my plan
to do
is take 25 000 out from my
investment account put that towards a
down payment do a 15-year mortgage on a
225 thousand dollar house
is that a smart thing to do i could take
out more but i still want to keep that
emergency fund
but the arion man is projected about 10
increase in home values in the next year
dude you're a stud you're 22 and you're
making 80.
yes sir what do you do i'm a systems
engineer
good for you man you're killing it and
you're single
correct are you dating someone seriously
no sir i'm not okay all right
um the other question i do have is i am
i have a guaranteed at least ten
thousand dollar bonus next year and then
more than likely another additional 10
to 15 on top of that
so i should be slightly over 100 000 for
next year and
following years as well phenomenal okay
so uh i would just
adjust your plan slightly um because
i know from the data that we have having
studied 10
167 millionaires that
the typical millionaire has two primary
components to their first
million to five million dollar net worth
and you should be there by the time
you're 30 with the trek you're on
okay and if you want to get there the
shortest way
here's what the data tells us a paid for
house and loading up the 401 k
correct i do max out my 401k company
good matches five percent i put five
percent in and then invest the rest into
etfs and mutuals good
so what that tells me is the paid for
house is the next thing on the equation
agreed
agreed which means i'm keeping only the
emergency fund i'm dumping the entire
etf
onto this onto this thing as my down
payment to thereby have less debt to
reduce
and then i'm going to throw bonuses and
money i would have been throwing in the
etfs above
the fully funded 401k at this mortgage
dude your house is paid for by the time
you're 25 26 years old
you got it and you're rolling into
a house at that point that's probably
worth 500
and um you know and let's just go ahead
and run the math out on your 401k
to you know for what eight years and i
think you're a millionaire
got it that that's what i'm hearing i'm
doing this in my head pretty quick but i
think i'm pretty close
but uh and and here's the thing the
other thing that's going to happen is uh
you're you statistically are very likely
during this eight year period of time to
meet and marry
the love of your life at which point you
will discover you have bought the wrong
house
right new plan new house
and so that will adjust our little plan
upset the apple cart but that's okay
it's worth it it's worth the cost
brother
you'll still you're still going to get
there because you got a plan but here's
the thing
the two data points are full 401k paid
for house and if you're always aiming
back at those at the earliest possible
age
you're going to build the greatest
possible amount of wealth
awesome that's for your first 5 million
worth of
uh wealth and that's what a you know and
you know we call them everyday
millionaires or baby step millionaires
because they follow the baby steps
and i've met three out here in the lobby
today that followed the baby steps
over the last decade to 15 years and
been listening to this show one guy said
he'd been listening to the show 20 years
yeah you know and um he started doing
this stuff and he just you know got out
of debt
which gave him the ability to invest and
pay off his home yeah we were talking
earlier about changing your family tree
it's a compounding effect not just
financially financially mathematically
it's a compounding effect in the
decision making you make different
decisions
two and three and four steps later
because of those first decisions so i i
love to see how
that can have a ripple effect for the
rest of your life and i'm starting to do
some writing on this millionaire stuff
because i'm starting to see some nuances
with our baby step millionaire community
um and that's what i'm calling it for
right now i may change the name of it
but i mean that's that's i'm starting to
and one thing i've noticed is is that
the millionaire
that sometimes what keeps people off the
track from being a millionaire
is they want to try to be a billionaire
and a bill
billionaires are a billion is a thousand
million
and uh in the forbes 400 i i got to look
it up fresh
it's been a year since i've looked it up
i need to look it up again
but in the forbes 400 it was that almost
all the forbes 400 are billionaires now
the 400 wealthiest people in america it
used to be three quarters of were but i
think they just about all are now
and like 70 of them are first-generation
billionaires
but the way you become a billionaire is
different
okay explain that than the way you
become a millionaire because the typical
millionaire the one to five million
first thing that happens to billionaires
is obviously first they become a
millionaire
right before they become billionaires
right but the difference from jumping
from five million
to a thousand million
is a big jump yeah okay so you get that
first five million the way we're talking
about here walking the baby steps that's
a
baby step millionaire but very few but
billionaires didn't use their 401k and
they're paid for house to become a
billionaire right
in almost every case they um
started a business and took it public
or didn't but they uh the business
uh somehow there was a business leverage
angle
okay you know uh you know uh to where
you know oprah owns this massive media
empire
and that's what made her a billionaire
it wasn't getting paid to do the oprah
show
right she she used her entrepreneurial
skills behind the scenes to build and
she's a billionaire mm-hmm
uh or uh the kathy family you know
chick-fil-a yeah
true cathy passed away but he was a
billionaire and the kids are
uh but that's the value of chick-fil-a
yeah it
gives them that the business value uh
the hobby lobby family the green family
uh again it was the value of that it
wasn't working a job and loading money
in the 401k they got them there
uh so they worked the job and load the
401k and along the way they became
millionaires
but then the way they make this huge
leap but the difference but people have
in their mind when they say wealthy
what billionaires do you know private
jets right
uh expensive cars six houses
millionaires don't have any of that
millionaires don't have private jets and
expensive cars and four houses
yeah they don't billionaires do right
but if you try to jump from where you
are
to billionaire you make a lot of
mistakes on get rich quick
yeah yeah because you're you're skipping
you you gotta do the tortoise
first yeah yeah and win the race to get
in that one to five
and then that positions you to do some
of these other things yeah
and and you can go big from there it's
interesting but uh
uh you know it it but if you try to if
you think of wealthy as a billionaire
then it's unattainable number one number
two you start doing stupid stuff to try
to get there before you do the basics
yeah
so do the baby step millionaire first
then start thinking about billionaire
level stuff yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five our famous ten dollar sale
is back including uh
her book number one bestseller business
boutique equipping women to make money
doing what they love
we've had over 40 best-selling books
here at ramsey
including a few of mine and that
includes the total money makeover and
they're 10
each now this is a hardback book this is
60 off
you can't get this kind of deal anywhere
else you wanna get the total money
makeover for ten dollars
a guy here bought a case a while ago
yeah i saw that i mean yeah
ten dollars a piece my gosh i mean think
about that that's a nice
high quality nice gift to give a friend
so
give them christy's book rachel's books
uh anthony's books
uh ken coleman the loney's quick read is
out there for ten dollars on anxiety
uh it's all there and you can get it all
at ramseysolutions.com and our online
store
and that's not all we got a gift for you
as well if you enter to win our ramsey
cash giveaway we're giving away 500
cash every week and a grand prize of
five thousand dollars cash
saying you can enter up to once a day uh
for extra chances to win so make sure
make sure you go to ramseysolutions.com
giveaway and enter once a day
there's no purchase necessary must be 18
or older or you can text
cash to 33789 text cash
to 33789 to enter our
giveaway now open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life your money
it is a free call thanks for joining us
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run
every month you'll save even more use
the promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal rules and restrictions
apply
today's question comes from amanda in
colorado she writes i make 100 000
a year and i'm on baby step 2 with 55
000
in debt i want to switch careers and
become a financial coach
my plan was to keep my current job until
i'm debt free
but i've been offered a position working
15 hours a week and earning
40 000 a year it would be an excellent
financial base
while building my coaching business
should i wait until i'm out of baby step
2 or make this change
now i'm curious your thoughts on this
one
because you you're in baby step two he
got fifty five thousand dollars of debt
make it a hundred thousand dollars a
year which is awesome
that's a good shovel to get to knock
that out
but wants to start a financial coaching
business well even if she didn't have
the debt let's just pretend she know the
debt okay she makes a hundred thousand
dollars a year
and she wants to drop to 40. yeah with
zero on the side hustle right now
yeah what would you tell her on that i
would say no i mean you
all get sad hustle get the boat closer
to the dock yeah
build it up on the side the thing is
that i think it's interesting that it
sounds like is appealing to her is the
limited amount of hours but what we see
people do more often than not that makes
them successful is they they work
in the nights and the weekends they work
on the side and
and even though it feels like for a
season you're working a full-time job
because two full-time jobs because you
are
it's the safer route to get to where you
want to be where you're doing that thing
full-time and the
the finances are there to support you
it's not a wish and a prayer and i hope
that the money is going to be there when
you make the job
it puts a different um let me tell you
nothing smells as bad as a broke
salesman yeah you're they feel that
desperation except a financial counselor
financial coach that's broke yeah that's
that's probably not that's probably
oxymoronic
so yeah uh yeah what you want to do is
start your financial coaching business
as a side hustle
get it growing and let's get some income
coming in now if you told me you were
making
uh 30 or 40 on your side hustle
financial coaching business and you
wanted to drop to 40.
now we've got a total of 80 and we're
dropping from 100 down to 80 hoping we
can make up the other 20. that boat's
close enough to the dock
you're not going to get wet but there's
the boat you can't even see the boat now
yeah because it's zero yeah it's out
there in the fog somewhere and you're
just gonna jump in and start swimming
hope you find it
right you know that that's you're gonna
drown well it's it's interesting because
she said it would be an excellent
financial base while building my
coaching business a better financial
base is a hundred thousand dollars a
year while building your coaching
business
there you go even better 140 000 a year
yeah
and you're a debt free yeah because you
made 40 on your coaching business
and then it's a no-brainer to quit right
debt-free you're making 80
when you quit with the 40 and the 40.
right i'm making that number up but it
could be 45 sure
but you need to have and it's not 10
yeah
you don't want i mean if you're making
40 on your site on your little part-time
thing
and you didn't make 10 that's 50. you
cut your income in half the boat's not
close enough the dock anytime you're
going to jump
uh unless you get fired from an income
to a self-employed income go ahead and
get the side hustle up because i'm
telling you make different decisions
when you're not broke
yeah when you're running a business and
you're broke
and you have to make money by friday to
eat it changes your decision-making
paradigm
and it damages it it sucks the joy out
of it too the fun for why you started it
it takes the fun out of it and to your
point the customers feel it because
you're
desperate they feel that but you don't
have to you can still
start your side financial coaching
business you don't have to have just
this job you just find the hours in
different times
to be able to do that build it up on the
side absolutely
absolutely open phones here at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five dalton is in oklahoma
city hi
dalton how are you i'm good it's awesome
to talk to you mr ramsey
you too sir what's up uh so i got a
question um i'm in baby step two
um i've got some student loan debt and
then uh truck
debt um i actually just listed my truck
last night i'm going to
end up selling it and i just want to
know
what kind of car i need to be looking
for after i can sell it and
what price range how much student loan
debt on it
uh 46. what do you owe
uh 24 and like kelly blue booked it for
32 to between 32 000 35 000.
wow so you put on the market for how
much
uh 34. nice truck and
yeah yeah it's a bad purchase but um
but it's a sweet truck yeah okay
but i want to get rid of it and how old
are you student loan as quick as
possible 27.
and what do you make did you say uh 86
that's for you yeah good for you all
right
and how much student loan debt again
forty six thousand okay you told me this
but
i'm trying to wrap my brain around all
these different numbers okay so
uh if you sell the truck for 30 and you
got six thousand dollars in your pocket
and you bought a six thousand dollar car
you'd have no car payments and you'd be
only attacking your student loan debt
right
yes sir so yeah your budget ought to be
what cash you get in your hand from from
the truck sale
net of uh net of your debt
so you pay cash for a little get around
car and uh
you know four five six thousand or
whatever it is you end up with right
or a little bit less but i mean really
if you buy a thousand dollar car and put
4 000 towards the debt
that doesn't fix anything you're 86 now
without the truck payments what fixes it
you're
shedding yourself of a 600 truck payment
right
yes sir yeah yeah that was kind of my
question if i could
if i could sell it for like the 32 or 33
and if i could make you know eight or
nine off of that
that's fine anywhere in there yeah
because here's the thing
okay let's say you buy a six thousand
dollar truck and you put three thousand
dollars towards it or you buy a nine
thousand dollar truck and you don't put
anything towards it
you haven't changed your student loan
equation that much what changed the
equation was getting rid of the truck
what changed the equation was you make
86 000 and you are now game on
you are you are a man with a plan that's
what's changing the equation
you're the secret sauce so the amount
that you use from the truck
to put towards the student loans is not
what's going to fix this it's getting
rid of the truck that fixes it
and the fact that you're freaking paying
attention now and don't have any truck
payments
okay you see what i'm saying
mathematically that's the case yep
yep that was termed my thinking was yeah
so whatever you want
whatever you make on the truck you can
spend up to that
on a car but not a dime more
gotcha or less you could spend two
thousand dollars less
it wouldn't be a bad exercise to you
know just
as a matter of self discipline because
here's what's gonna happen
you're gonna be a hundred percent
debt-free in
less in about a year okay yeah yeah
and then you're gonna be saving up for
your emergency fund and then you're
gonna save up to move up and truck
because you should you don't need to be
driving a six thousand 000 truck making
80
grand 90 grand and no debt you probably
could move up in truck then and pay cash
so you're going to move back up later so
this is a temporary move it's probably a
two to three year move is all
so you're fine really good job dude
good job
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two
mitchell is up next in lincoln nebraska
hi mitchell welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thanks for having me absolutely
how can we help
well i'm i'm in a bit of a predicament
it's brought i brought it upon myself of
course but let me tell you about myself
i'm 27 years old
in 2014 i got an associate's degree and
in two weeks i'll have a bachelor's of
architecture
good for you thank you i have a private
pilot's license with a hundred hours
and um forty five thousand dollars in
student loans
about fifteen thousand dollars cash on
hand twenty five thousand in an ira
and i paid about six hundred per month
in rent um so i'm switch i'm considering
switching careers to aviation
because i'm finding i'm just not very
happy in architecture
it's going to take a lot of money to
switch and time
and i'm just not really sure if it's the
smartest thing but i think maybe i
should choose happiness goals through
money
what do you think well i don't think
they're exclusive from each other
that's a that's a that's the dangerous
assumption that somehow happiness has to
be associated with being broke
um happiness has to be associated with
not making money
okay so i'm going to choose option c
none of the above let's find a way to
live a great life and make a lot of
money doing it
and that that you know that'll make you
happy money won't make you happy but
um you know this i i often hear people
say things like well i'm gonna go to
work for this uh
thing that has meaning in my life but
they don't pay anything
and i'm like well i got a lot of meaning
in my life and i make a lot of money
so because i help a lot of people so
they're not mutually exclusive you can
do both as a matter of fact there should
be
a tie and a capitalistic economy to
serving
an income and so um
i think you back up pan back a little
bit more and say okay what are the steps
to get you where you want to be when
you're 34 years old or 37 years old a
decade from today
what have you got to do to get where you
want to go and what's the shortest
path to get where you want to go and if
you're going to be an architect and
you're going to be miserable well that's
not that's not
that option is off the table i'm curious
why are you miserable like what's what's
what did you
what got you into it that was true that
you loved it or wanted to do it and what
has changed that you no longer love it
what's going on
well i guess i thought it was a logical
continuation for my studies and
i've always i thought like it was a
strong suit for me
you know i was just playing with my
strengths and decided that was a good
field but maybe perhaps my
interactions with other people is the
most important thing
as to why i'm choosing another field i
don't even really have work experience
i'm mostly going off of my educational
experiences
your interactions with other people
turned you off on architecture what does
that mean
i don't know it's just a very
egotistical field maybe
not really and you could you could
decide that it's not
not really you don't have to be that i
work with architects every week
and i don't have any i don't deal with
any of them that have ego problems
i wouldn't put up with them having an
ego problem
but i mean i'm building two buildings
right now we're working with
architectural firm and there's five
different architects involved in that
and they're all just really nice people
so if you let me ask you this
mitchell if you take the people out of
it and your ideas about is your
professor's a jerk is that what you
meant
i mean oh i got him okay all right okay
the actual act of architecture what you
do
okay what you have learned to do in
school and what you would be doing
hypothetically
do you like doing that type of work
i don't think i do anymore okay i think
i'd rather fly a plane
well yeah it's addicting
the problem with aviation is it's a drug
uh ask any pilot they'll i mean i i i've
been told a thousand times don't get
your pilot's license ramsey because
you're gonna get sucked in it's like
golf
i mean you're gonna get sucked into the
vortex and you can't get out
um so yeah i mean it's
the pipe my i mean pilots just live to
land and take off i mean it's just like
i think
and so um i don't doubt that i i
i
i'm okay if you want to go be a pilot
i'm not okay if you want to go in a
hundred thousand dollars in debt to do
that
and i'm not okay if you say that means
i'm gonna be broke when i'm 37 and
that's call and call that happy
that's just not true okay so you need a
different track on your pilot career
that cause you the cause that causes you
to not be broke
as a pilot pilots can make good money
and do make good money um
i mean private jet pilots as an example
you know they make 100 and a half on
average
and that you know a lot of architects
don't make that so you can get there but
you know it's just a matter of what what
you know the hours logging and the
uh you know the lessons and your license
now but i assume your license on
turboprop right
oh no i just have a very basic um ptl
yeah
yeah okay and so you got a lot of work
to do to make any money because nobody
pays anybody to fly what you're licensed
to fly
right yeah it'll take at least two years
probably 50 grand
yeah okay here's here's what i would
tell you to do
i think christy
that we heard i i i'm gonna i
i don't agree with the conclusion you
came to i
i think you had a jerk professor or two
and it made your life miserable and so
every time you picked up
uh uh work you know open up the cad
drawing to work on this thing you hated
architecture because the jerk that you
were dealing with
or two or three jerks you were dealing
with or the way some of the students
acted
or whatever and and christie challenged
you on actually doing the work
i think because there's correlations
between pilot
work you know the the amount of
technical detail that you have to do
and the amount of technical detail
you're a technical detail guy because
both of these things have that
yes okay and you said it's a strength of
yours and it is
i think there's a way you can make a
living doing architecture while you do
your
pilot work i don't think you have to
abandon architecture
and go live on poverty while you do your
pilot work i think you go and get your
architecture's license
get a job being an architect and then
work on your hours on the weekends work
on your hours at night you're going to
pay to do this it's going to take a
while
and you take that two years that you're
talking about
and you've got to fund it right and the
way to fund it is be an architect well
and just in a situation where you're not
dealing with jerks yes it reframes
architecture for you gives you an
opportunity to have a good experience in
architecture and actually see what that
could be like maybe you do like it you
rediscover
it also helps you resist the urge to
just be scattered and change your mind
every two years
i just don't want you changing your mind
every two years like stick with this
let's give it a chance and then if you
want to keep doing the pilot thing on
the side that's great and you can switch
gears when you can pay for it you've got
a little bit of money but
i just got this sense that it's like
well i don't like this anymore i want to
do that so i don't like this more i want
to do
no we if we're going to make progress we
need to stick with something so give
this a chance let's
let's wipe a clean slate from the bad
professor give it a chance
make some money and then like you said
just you can continue to explore the
pilot thing on the side as well
and move towards that if you want to if
you know i had this friend that was
married to a guy who was an absolute
twerp
and he was a jerk i mean he mistreated
her in every possible way
and you know i slept around all over the
place had affairs all this stuff and
finally she had wised up and dumped the
jerk right
because he was he was a nightmare uh and
she went through this period of time
where all men are evil right
yeah that's that that's that wound that
trauma is speaking yeah i'm gonna
protect myself and it's like you know
and but all men aren't evil right just
because he was a jerk right
and so it's the same exact thing you
know you you got traumatized
right by this this process and it you
know and it's not that marriage is bad
it's not that men are bad you just had a
bad one right it's not that architecture
is bad
you just had a bad one right right and
so um
you know i i think you need to give this
a chance i'm not saying when you're 37
you won't be a pilot
i'm saying that's okay to be a pilot to
have that as the goal
but let's let's use a different path to
get there that involves architecture
giving it a second chance yeah
here's the thing if then you walk away
from the architecture after having done
it four or five years
you'll never look back you'll never
regret it if you do all this work and
then you never go do it
you may have some regrets yeah you may
have good point and i'm gonna miss that
that's a good point
so i want you to give her give her a
little run here won't kill you
and uh you're not gonna you know you
gotta do something because you gotta
fund this pilot's thing so that's a good
way to do it
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today isaiah 6 8 then i
heard the voice of the lord saying whom
shall i send
and who will go for us and i said here i
am
send me ralph waldo emerson said don't
go where the path may lead go instead
where there is no path and leave a trail
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five bob's in sacramento hey bob
welcome to the ramsay show
hi there uh scenario is
i've done everything wrong according to
you dave
thank you for your honesty bob i'm sorry
my wife and i
have a mortgage on our home of about
550 000. we also lost the home
in august to the wildfires oh
no i'm so sorry i'm sorry we had just
refinanced
from a 3.5
to a 2.75 in may
i got another call from the mortgage
company in november and said would you
like to
lower that to 2.25
and i said can you finance air and they
said yes
so i took the 2.25 loan
i have enough capital that i could pay
off the loan
the only problem is the price of two
befores has doubled
and with the insurance settlement i
don't know how much home i can build
if i pay off the loan so i need
for your wise advice so what will they
give you for the burned house
uh as much as
nine hundred and two thousand okay and
what is the lot worth
uh four hundred thousand
okay all right do you and do you get the
lot
i mean okay yeah you get you get 902
from the mortgage company you pay off
550
and you get the 902
is the absolute max with everything
yeah furnishings and everything uh no
that's just the house okay that would be
all the extra add-ons that the state of
california has added such as sprinklers
solar and an electric vehicle water
charging station and any cost overruns
above the policy
okay so will they write you a check
for can you talk them up or you're in
your attorney get them to give you a
check for nine hundred thousand dollars
you pay and you pay off the mortgage out
of that i'm afraid
not i have the cash on hand that i could
pay it no that's not what i'm asking i'm
trying to figure out how much money you
can get out of this freaking insurance
company and walk away
uh probably
i'm not sure let's make up another
number
okay i'm going to call it 800. okay okay
for example purposes you got to pay off
a 550 000
mortgage and so that leaves you uh
250 000 and you have a 400 000
lot that you sell for 400 000 scrape it
and sell it
okay now you've got
650 000 in your pocket plus the money
that you already told me you had to pay
off the house with
you've got other capital right correct
yes and it amounts to how much
uh approximately
400 000. okay so
now you got a million dollars to buy a
house with
and i would buy a used house i wouldn't
try to build right now
building my wife and i are still
debating about the politics of
california we'd like to find somewhat
someplace a little more sane yeah well a
million dollars will buy a lot more
other places in sacramento sacramento is
a wonderful town i like sacramento
but it is an expensive real estate
market yes um and if you move it's not
it's not
it's not orange county uh silicon valley
expensive but it's expensive
and so uh it is california expensive you
know so
i mean if you said we wanted to move to
x y state
now a million dollars gonna buy a lot
more and this is your escape route
you don't build you don't rebuild here
have you got any wise words that i could
use to convince my better half
about leaving california or about
rebuilding both
number one rebuilding's not going to
make sense
because it's the worst possible time to
buy two befores
and uh steel and copper
and plywood there's a shortage on all of
it right now and it's all doubled and in
some cases tripled
and so you're gonna have trouble you're
gonna have a lot of trouble putting back
a house
even the size that you had before you're
going to come out
hundreds of thousands of dollars ahead
not
building
okay because of the because of building
cost right now
yes you know it's uh if you want to
build a house it's okay right now but
this is
you know but but if you can avoid
building one right now i would
i would wait a year or maybe two if you
really really really want to build and
there's nothing tying you to this lot
scrape it and sell it okay now you got
now you got a million dollars piled up
and then you can buy in sacramento or
you can leave california that's a
separate decision than whether to build
on this lot
yes two different decisions you can make
both of them
you can make a decision to leave
california or stay in california but i'm
scraping this lot and selling it for 400
grand
or 500 grand somebody'll probably buy it
because there's a shortage
and um you know you may get great price
on a silly thing
and get a and you know and
here's the thing other thing that's
going through my head and i need to say
it out loud
one of the top 10 things that will put
you in the hospital is
losing a home to a fire it is highly
emotional
it's like a death yes
i mean i've gone through the stages dave
yeah you go through the grieving stages
as if you
you know you know and so it's you know
bankruptcy
divorce house fire loss of a child
these are the top 10 things you know you
get two or three of them in one year
you're in the hospital
i mean it'll take you out it's a it's
highly traumatic
and what i'm trying to do also is give
your emotions some
uh margin rebuilding a house building a
house is freaking traumatic
yes let's not add trauma on trauma you
know
you building a house is for people that
are in a real healthy situation and
really excited about doing it and want
to do it you're
you're you're building out of necessity
or some kind of a grasping thing going
on here and it's
uh you know if your marriage isn't going
well and you want a divorce build a
house
you know that's that's that's the old
you know that's the truth because it'll
it's like you know some people are so
dumb they're like our marriage isn't
going good let's have kids maybe that'll
fix it you know
that's a dumb butt idea you know they do
that that'll break you real fast
that'll do it that'll end everything so
i think i'm just trying to love you
and say man if i were you i'd want to
curl up somewhere
in a snuggie and just get warm you know
you've been out in the cold it's you're
you're
you're raw you know and i just man i
wanna if i was you that's what i'd wanna
do
may i throw something else into the mix
quickly
my wife and i are here in maryland
taking care of her father who's in stage
four kidney failure
currently three percent kidney function
oh my gosh
so you know the line god keep
or god only gives you as much as you can
handle
my line is he has us confused with
someone else
he took you right up to the line anyway
yeah so
it you know it might be that you don't
need to make this decision right now
well trust me the insurance company and
the mortgage company
are hounding us have have you done your
repairs yet
yeah and okay well go ahead and turn it
back on them and go
just write us a check and we'll call it
a day
so you know they have written the one
check and the mortgage company
has it but the mortgage companies paid
off
uh well they are holding the money in
trust
okay well tell the tell the uh insurance
company if they that you want to just
settle and if you don't have an attorney
you may need one
because you may need a buffer between
you and these characters right now
they're settling a whole bunch of claims
over there and i don't want you to get
stuck
yeah so you may need some representation
especially while you're dealing with
your father-in-law's illness
you're in a point of weakness there to
negotiate so yeah you do have your
you do have yourself full bob i'm sorry
wow
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you